okay sir
okay good afternoon everybody um welcome
to
this executive meeting um item one on
the agenda is attendances
i've received apologies from councillors
right and slater
um and also councillor harding who is
away on holiday
um and i know that councillor carter is
um hoping to join the call slightly is
detained on another meeting so may or
may not
be with us um item two is questions from
members of the public i am aware that
one question has been
um received it has been agreed because
of the format of this meeting that we
will
hear the question um in the meeting now
and then a written response will be sent
by the executive member counselor
outside so if i could ask joe maloney
from democratic services to
share the question for us please john
thanks leader
um the question i will read out to you
as written
uh just for members information there
was a map included on the email
which is just an illustrative location
plan
the text of the question is as follows
dear counselor stephen adshead
my name is robert bacon and i have been
discussing proposals for change to
oxford road in ultranam
with councillor sean anstey cbe
conservative member for bowdoin ward
shadow executive member for children's
social care
traffic council and sir graham brady
i have obtained overwhelming support
from residents of oxford road and have
numerous signed petitions
in support of the following a
making oxford road a residence access
only
brackets or dead end either at rigby
street
or at the junction with hale road close
brackets
reducing traffic flow and subsequently
encouraging walking and cycling
whilst at the same time reducing i think
it means wear and tear it actually says
water and
tear on the text on what is essentially
a cut through route to hail road c-map
b oxford road brackets and peter street
close brackets resurfacing
the road is in terrible condition and
has been allowed to deteriorate terribly
over the years
which also impacts drainage causing
flooding
and subsequent property damage as a
result and making it dangerous for
cyclists and road users alike
c pavement refurbishments
the pavements are in very poor condition
and slope badly towards the road
some residents are elderly and use
wheelchairs
and have to use the road because of poor
pavement condition
and the very obvious slope especially on
the right
side as you travel down oxford road fyi
it's one way by way of support for our
proposals
i would like to request that funding is
allocated from the covid19
walking and cycling funds etc to ensure
these changes are put in place swiftly
additional additional benefits would be
to provide a direct walking stroke
cycling link between
altringman hale and as oxford road is
purely a cut-through road to hail road
where access already exists via the main
road
brackets ashley road closed brackets it
would have no
major impact on traffic flow and or
affect any emergency services
kind regards robert bacon
thank you joe so as indicated um before
you share the question with us
councillor assad will
organize a written response to be sent
to mr bacon
copying again i think is his appropriate
counselor anstey and graeme brady and
perhaps the other voting ward members as
well if that's okay steve thank you
um item three is declarations
of interest are there any declarations
from
members of the exec
thanks um item for matters from council
or overview and scrutiny committees we
have today
received a written report as to the work
of the
pandemic exclusion committee that has
been set up in the short-term counsellor
act and is there anything to add to that
[Music]
thank you leader uh can you hear me yes
come on now
can you hear hello
is it just me struggling to hear
maybe closer to your uh main
router sir please
no i think we've got some technical
issues with counseling i'm able to do
that to be honest
so yeah
okay well we have received the report in
writing
so um we we have had a
an update as to the um to the work of
the committee
which which obviously we're very
grateful for in these
um unusual times so we will um
thank the committee for their work and
for sharing that that with us
this afternoon okay um we will move on
to item five which is the public
interest report by the local government
ombudsman
into complaints against the traffic
council waste collection service
councillor ad said
please thank you a leader
can you hear me yes thank you
right okay yes uh the report details
that the outcome of the investigation by
the ombudsman
into uh complaints with the waste
services and details
the actions taken by the council to help
address the issues arising from
the ongoing report the original alert
complaints date back
to between may and july 2019
the overriding theme of these particular
complaints was a failure
to return bins to the correct location
and mr garden and food waste collections
the council acknowledged that there has
been issues with the waste collection
service
and was working with its service
provider amy to improve
the waste collection service in response
to john woodson's draft report the
council advised the ombudsman
that the council had already identified
areas of service failure
and were informal process with amy to
review
performance and address service delivery
issues
with a view to significantly improving
the level of service it provides to
residents
the council has actively engaged with
the recommendations in the book
to ensure that the complainants the
complaints have seen an improvement
in the service they receive they have
all confirmed that they are now
satisfied with the level of service they
receive
a further review of the complaints
system will take place
including reviewing the steps suggested
by the ombudsman
to give residents a further opportunity
to engage
with the waste service before contacting
the ombudsman
amy have appointed three new supervisors
in the last year
making a total of five in february they
had
a management change with a new waste
operations manager
and a new principal operations
manager now impulse they've also engaged
a company called on civils
an independent company to monitor
the service engage with residents and
resolve issues with their collections
amy has recruited to all load of
vacancies
which should lead to an improvement in
the service as reliance on agency staff
is vastly reduced
use of agency staff is only required to
cover sickness and holidays
section 4.2 of the report sets out the
eight recommendations
five of which will be completed and
following approval
of this report this afternoon or further
uh two of these will progress to
completion
of the eighth one to actually ask over
me and scrutiny to review the work
and see if the changes have resulted in
serious improvements
with that leader i will uh move the
report and actually ask if we had any
questions
thank you
i'll just take a glass of water that's
all right just pop yourself on mute
steve that's fine
um are there any questions from members
of the executive if so could you
indicate
um either in the chat or
um i'll just come in no
okay moving on to questions more widely
counselor evans has a comment
uh thank you leader it was just picking
up uh thank you for the report and it'd
be
interesting to see how we can progress
this over the over the coming weeks and
months
um section 4.2 item c uh
suggests that the overview and scrutiny
committee are going to consider uh
changes etc that
that's effectively not meeting at this
point in time
let's hope it potentially by september
are the is the pandemic scrutiny
committee going to pick up
this in the interim or is it just going
to be parked until september
council answered do you want to respond
to that
i mean i'm not a little scrutiny so i'm
not sure and obviously we'll i will
discuss this with senior officers on
this uh
later sale tomorrow and actually uh see
if we can get in touch with scoot and
see what arrangements they wish to make
uh i mean obviously we have the
emergency scrutiny committee measures
and and that's appropriate to do that
and obviously the sooner we can do this
the better in my view and i can't see
why
we are trying to get back to business as
usual and i'm certainly keen to actually
have this
in the system now and actually looked at
quickly so we'll get back to council
evans on that as soon as we can and
confirm
what's been decided if that's acceptable
thank you
thank you councillor yeah i mean it just
just just as an aside on that just just
for clarity i would think it probably
falls outside of the remit
of the terms of reference of the
pandemic scrutiny committee um
you know i mean obviously we don't
normally meet in august anyway so if we
are in a position to start up
normal scrutiny arrangements from
september then we should be well placed
to
press on with that work without much um
outside usual delay are there any other
questions or comments on that at all
just checking no it doesn't appear to be
so okay
um the report excuse me the report has a
series of
recommendations can they be agreed by
the executive please
thank you um item six is
the corporate plan council of freeman
please
thank you
thank you leader can you hear me yes
please
thank you by way of introduction during
the course of the last 12 months
we've been reporting on a quarterly
basis the performance of the corporate
plan
and today i've got two reports uh for
you
the corporate plan quarter four
performance and the annual summary of
the financial year
1920. as we'll all be aware the council
identified seven strategic priorities
that we believe are crucial to enabling
trafford residents
uh businesses and staff to thrive these
priorities set out our aspirations for
our people
place and communities and how they can
affect and improve their daily lives
and as a reminder the priorities are
building quality affordable and social
housing health and well-being
successful and thriving places children
young people
pride in our area green and connected
and targeted support
the corporate plan describes how these
priorities will be delivered over
through a three-year period
april 19 to march 2022 this
ensures that staff partners and
residents understand the actions
required by them for the council
and identifies resources available to
deliver the stated aims and objectives
the plan helps the council and teams to
monitor performance
to make use of the opportunities
presented and control our systems and
structures
effectively i'll start then with 6a the
quarter
corporate plan quarter 4 performance
the quarter 4 report provides a summary
of the performance from the 1st of
january to the 31st of march 2020
this period was also impacted by the
coronavirus pandemic
each priority has a summary of activity
for quarter four
these activities are a combination of
both qualitative and quantitative
activity
and the output for each quarter depends
on the deliverables that are achieved
for that quarter
the key performance indicators are on
page three of the report and they are
are red amber and green in status
so some of the key highlights are the
number of housing completions has
already achieved the annual target
the traffic pledge far exceeded the
annual target and helped 249 local
people
back into employment with 86 being
helped in this particular quarter
we have continued in traffic to maintain
a low level of 16 to 17 year olds who
are not in education training or
employment
and at 1.96 is an improvement
on last year's performance and better
than the national average
other areas worthy of note include
trafford's affordable housing fund which
was established in september 18.
this has enabled the council to fund the
development of 30 socially rented
properties in timperley
in partnership with trafford housing
trust the development received planning
approved in february this year
and is due to complete next year six
community hubs were mobilized by the
voluntary sector and partners
to support residents in trafford as a
result of the pandemic
traffic companies entitled to the
extended business rates release scheme
in retail hospitality and leisure have
received 100 relief
on their 2021 bill meaning they have
nothing to pay this year
100 business assists were made in
quarter four
and 288 supported over the year
and the annual target was 200. council
staff were provided with laptops and
equipment to work from home
microsoft teams have been installed to
support council staff
and to communicate and collaborate
virtually the trafford homeless strategy
was also approved
in march 19 covering the years 20
2020-24
in quarter four 2019 20
95 households prevented from becoming
homeless
overall in 19 2019 20
there were 427 people prevented from
becoming
homeless against a target of four
hundred for any indicator off target
with a red or amber status we project
the report provides an exception report
that has been prepared to outline why
performance is below target
and what action is in place to improve
performance
for quarter four there are five
indicators with number status and one
with a red status
and exception reports have been
completed and plus an additional
exception report
for complaints as it is whilst it's not
a specific indicator
uh there has been an increase since the
last quarter as we will know
uh from the previous item that was uh
the council as had spoke to and at this
stage leader
i'd like to invite questions from
anybody on
the quarter four reports before i move
on to the annual report
questions or comments on the quarter
four report from members of the
executive
any questions or comments more widely
no okay counselor frame if you want to
proceed to the annual report please
thank you leader the purpose of the
annual report is to tell
traffic council's story to all including
our residents and staff of what we've
delivered from april 19 to march 2020.
it clearly communicates the council's
values and the key metrics
and the major achievements of the past
year in a visually appealing way
the case studies in the report put the
focus on the people
that have been impacted by the council's
work and brings to life
each of the priorities in a very real
way it demonstrates the human element of
what we do
how we do and how well we are doing it
some of the highlights from the annual
report include the trafford older people
strategy housing strategy 20 2025 was
launched in march 2020
this strategy looks to extend the
housing options and support developed
for older people
in trafford to enable them to live
independently
the launch of the trafford local care
organization tlco
and the published locality plan the
investment of 150 000 that was secured
from trafford house interest
to address health inequalities the
developed master plans for the civic
quarter
stratford and stanford quarter trafford
are moving on to traffic educational
attainment levels
they're some of the best in the country
um 11 of the trafford parks have been
awarded green flags this is up from one
in the previous year
the opening of the metrolink uh traffic
park line ahead of schedule
um and the the resigning of the armed
forces covenant in support of the
servicemen and women
and also a big shift this last year in
inquiries shifted to online
significantly higher than the annual
target but
you know what we're looking at now is
we're going through a review
and a stock take of our strategic
priorities and key deliverables under
each priority
this review of the deliverables and
measurements measures for the coming
year is critical
given the impact of covid19 on services
and resources and the recovery that is
underway these are being reviewed
through heads of service strategic leads
and departmental management teams so we
can ensure the measures
and and the timeliness of the timelines
are accurate and achievable
the review will also include a stop take
of the plan on a page
we always said we would constantly
review an update after the first year
and the unprecedented changes and
challenges we've faced it's appropriate
to revisit all aspects
and refine as necessary and in respect
of that review
we expect a report to be delivered to
the executive in the autumn with it with
it then coming on
for on back to executive around about
that time
thank you leader thank you councillor
freeman are there any
questions or comments remember to be
executive
okay councillor coggins please thank you
leader um yes i welcome the update
and um particularly the review and stock
take i hear is ongoing
and in september last the climate
emergency task and finish group
recommended that climate action actually
be put in there as a priority in the
corporate plan
at the moment we're still measuring
ourselves against the old plan that
lumps climate action
in with a new road building under the
reassuring title
green and connected with the leaf symbol
and so i'm keen to know that
this will be under consideration or
indeed prioritized as one of the new
priorities
and i suppose keen to know the exact
feel they're actually
a year and a half on from our climate
emergency and
10 months on from this recommendation
this has really been treated with the
urgency that it needs thank you
counselor freeman uh just to reassure
cancer cloggings
uh that will be taken into consideration
uh uh
councillor in relation to the stocktake
uh
as of when we go through that uh it's
been on our list
and um i would invite council ad said to
probably talk to you about whether you
think we've made enough progress
uh in respect of climate change
thank you any comments councillor
answered
yes uh thank you leader so there will be
a report coming to executive in within
the next
few months i think it's obviously it's
been delayed because of covid and i've
been pursuing that
um obviously for some time now but it's
obviously it's unfortunate but it seems
to affect a lot of things but
rest assured it's something that we are
taking seriously and we're looking at
and keen to get us
in there but it's just unfortunately
taking a bit longer uh with the
pandemic we've got it long rest assured
it will be coming to the executive
in the near future hopefully that's
helpful
thank you and counselor boys please
yeah thank you thank you leader it's
just i'm just trying to
get my head around one statistic
mentioned there and that's what to do
with the number of green
flag parks uh councillor freeman said
they've gone up from one
to 11. i wasn't quite aware that we've
gone down to one from the previous one
we've gone from up by one until we let
um
11 of our parks have been awarded a
green flag
thank you okay any further questions or
comments on this
item counselor evans
thank you leader i was just picking up
on there 163 people
supported through bed for the night um
and 718 provided with
food vouchers etc which is great and
how are our resources standing i've had
a few
uh issues with respect to people at the
amblehurst which
are potentially not from our own borough
but are
there but with no food and no general
support
from across gm are we are we finding it
a struggle to support these people
and and how can we support these people
i understand it's a bed but it isn't it
haven't got any support wrapped around
it
it's certainly an issue that that
manifested itself
most clearly at the beginning of the
pandemic when i think other councils
within gm
were placing um residents in the
amblehurst and then reaching out to our
community hubs for support and provision
my understanding
um and it may be that the situation has
changed very recently and i've not been
further briefed is that um through the
working relationships that we have
um across greater manchester we were
able to
nip much of that issue in the bud and
there is significantly more support for
those people
from the authority placing them than
there was at this point perhaps
three months ago um so there's certainly
been
a substantial improvement in that regard
councilor evans but obviously if you're
still hearing of
specific cases feel free to let us know
and we'll take that away
i mean that was over the past set that
was over the past seven days later so it
it's still a
pertinent problem so okay we've been
talking thanks
um any other questions or comments
no okay the two we'll take the two
reports together 6a
and 6b so the um quarter full report and
then the overarching
manual report they're just for noting
their exec members happy to
note those reports please
thank you um item seven is the budget
monitoring for 2021
period two councillor ross please
thank you very much um i'm asking the
executive to note the
period two out turn report you'll see in
the report
the current projection is of a budget
shortfall of 17.7 million which
comprises the
covert 19 impact of 23.2 million
and a projected 5.5 million
underspend in core service budgets
however we need to treat that particular
figure with a great degree of caution
because this is very
early into the year um for making such
projections and a lot of that
short for is or underspenders in the
demand lead budget
so um we're best to treat that figure
with
caution um since this paper was
published we've got a bit more
information on the second of july
announcement which will help improve the
situation
but the it will not cover the full
extent of the projected deficit so
we are we are going to be receiving 1.8
million pounds
from the government as part of that
package that they announced on the 2nd
of july
we're going to have the ability to defer
losses um business rates and council tax
to future years which will help
us in this immediate year but obviously
store up
it well store up financial commitments
in in later years
um we've got this income scheme that's
been announced but we've not got the
detail for that
yet but as soon as we do we'll be able
to come back with a uh
a more accurate picture of the uh the
the budget situation in here
but i'm happy to take any questions
thank you council ross any questions or
comments from members of
the executive
no okay um questions or comments more
why the counselor coggins first and then
councillor myers please
thank you and uh and thanks for the
updates we've been getting as group
leaders as well on this it's been it's
been really useful to uh to have a good
grasp on what's been going on
and i just wanted some reassurances that
our uh medium and long-term strategies
on
active transport both on the a56 and
elsewhere are being taken into account
in terms of our financial situation and
sometimes it can be easy to think of
those things
in terms of a public health issue which
is obviously what's a huge advantage of
them at the moment
but of course we know from all the
evidence that actually making it easy
for people to move around uh freely
especially in the absence of public
transport we're going to face this
winter
and can really lead to an uptick in the
local economy
and and i'm just looking for
reassurances but all that is being
considered and that we're looking at
this in an evidence-based way and its
impact on our finances
thanks ask the ross you want to take
that one first
i am happy to take that and then i'll um
defer to either nikki or
stephen with specifics around the uh the
capital but now
absolutely as a as an executive we we do
um
see and value the importance of active
travel
um you'll see that um we're looking at
the way that we approach the capital
budget now for the year
um a large part of that is what funding
is already there and
and and how best we can um we can we can
work with the the current capital but
i'll just ask if
nikki first of all wants to come in and
then followed by stephen
i've said um with regards to individual
commitments
thanks nikki hi so anything which is
currently already committed
is is included in this report so
anything which is
is currently in the plan is is included
in this report
if it was made since the plan then it it
could well
be part of the cycle schemes that have
been announced as part of covert
and i'm afraid i don't know the detail
of those office of my head but i can
i can't find out the answer for you
thanks steve was there anything
from you on that in particular the
secular used to comment obviously that
uh
the funding for these kobe schemes are
actually not air monies they're coming
from special funds set
up from government which we're getting
through the gmca
and we're recharging them to those so
it's not actually their own funding on
that
so hopefully that shows you that that
won't have any impact on our programme
yeah i mean yeah and i recognize
councillor coggins asked about the the
medium and long term so we will
nikki will come back to you on that
thanks councillor there's 201
uh proposals that are more long-term
sessions and they should be
hopefully uh be able to look at those in
their near future
thanks cancer i said um cancer myers
please
yes thank you leader um can i ask about
uh
adults services and specifically uh page
eight
uh in table two about halfway down the
uh
down the actual note it says that
there's been a payment or it's been a
planned payment of 4.3 million pounds
to care providers for
additional costs to provide
sustainability in the market
that just seems quite a high figure
because
further down the same same page it says
they're also going to receive 2.3
million pound
for infection control can we just have a
bit more explanation please
yeah sure my understanding of that is
that it was to provide some
certainty to providers council ross you
wanted to come in on that are you happy
to
for me to ask diane to come here and
help if you just stay on
yeah could i stand to come in on that if
that's okay please
yes thank you linda can you hear me yes
thanks diane
thank you and just just for clarity so
the
the infection control grant was uh
passported through to the council with
the understanding
that the whole values would be
passported to providers
so it's set by a government on the
values that need to be given to the
providers both
around the personal protective equipment
um
isolating staff isolating customers in
care homes when they go in from hospital
reducing staff moving between sites etc
so
and most of those values are mandated
the partner the council
then took some decisions on was
supporting the occupancy rates in care
homes that dropped below 90 percent
which is set against their business
model most local authorities have done
something very very similar
those are under review again in august
as the
most of that money then is passported
through the covered funding in the ccg
so the adult social care budgets do look
quite confusing
at the moment because of the money
coming in and the money going out
both the providers and the recharging
through to the ccg
um if it would be helpful to do
something and
separate offline i'll happily go through
the detail with your counselor myers if
that would be
helpful to you yeah that'd be very
helpful i i understand the infection
controlled uh 2.27 million i understand
that
but it's the 4.3 million to pay for
empty beds
um they're not necessarily empty as the
additional beds we've purchased to
support people discharged from
hospital so we have blocked purchased a
number a number of beds
so that we have those facilities
available we have about 100
and they're in use at different times
throughout the
month or four months now and so they are
they aren't
empty they're in use but they move quite
quickly as people go into the bed to
recover
and then go home it's those discharge to
assess better supporting the discharges
thank you leader it's fine thanks
councilman
um and thanks diane for tibetan for the
offer to
to pick that up offline also are there
any other
um questions or comments on
this clearly i um a very important item
but also quite a challenging one for it
for us at the moment so thank you
councillor ross for that update the
report is for
um noting can that be noted please
i thank you and then
item 8 is councillor ross again with the
treasury management
annual performance report for 1920
councillor ross please
thank you yeah this report is the annual
report and it went to accounts and
audits last week and it's here
asking us to to to note so um obviously
it's a roundup of the previous year and
i'd like to take this opportunity to
give my thanks to the treasury
management team for their ongoing work
and looking ahead to what what what does
look like a very challenging year ahead
um if you read the report on the
forecast
thanks councillor ross um and this
report also goes in due course to
council i believe for noting so
um there are there are some some stages
to go with this
any questions or comments from members
of the executive
no more why do councilor myers please
yes thank you leader um can i ask is the
council actually considered
um an alternative to the public works
loan board
as an alternative fund for
a source of funding for for projects and
then secondly i noticed that the
amount we're lending to on the councils
has increased
quite dramatically over the year uh it's
actually gone up by
14.5 million can i ask how safe that
money is
if any of those councils were to declare
a
uh a problem with balancing their budget
council nice cancer ross bro i will ask
nikki to come in
at this point if that's okay sure
hi councillor myers yes um we have
um started to think about other um
forms of borrowing pwlb always used to
be
um very cheap um compared to others
and and also very easy to arrange
and those those two things are becoming
um
less advantageous now so we
we are looking around um for other forms
as well just to make sure we're
obviously getting
best value for money when we're when
we're investing for capital
um and your second question
um remind me what it was it was about
the uh
safety of the money how's that oh yes
yes so um lending money between
councils has been going on for for a
long long time
and and we actually borrow money from
other councils as well
for cash flow purposes so so we tend to
move money
um around between us on a short term
basis
most of our loans to other councils will
be on a short term basis probably
um six months or so i think
the government um
the covenant which comes from a public
sector organization
um even in light of the pandemic
is still gives it um a very good
credit rating um if you if we had
credit ratings i think it would it would
give us
still because of that because of that
covenant
leader can i come back i was
specifically interested should any of
those
those councils actually declare a
section 114 uh
notice
i i'm not entirely sure on the position
were they to
declare section 114 um as i understand
it they would still owe us the money
um i don't think we've got very much
money out with other councils at the
moment
but i will find out for you and i'll
come back to you
well the actual the actual figure nick
is 14.5 million
uh in the report that would have been at
the time though
um that that it will it will change on a
daily basis
so could we would we take that away
nikki clarify the position of knowing
what would happen if somebody were to
declare 114
and also the current amount that we've
got out would
would be useful i think if you could
provide that to council demise
councillor ross that would be great
thanks nikki um councillor evans
uh thank you lady i'd just like to uh
put on record our groups uh
thanks to the treasury team and for
putting
putting this report together and the
work that they have been thrown into
over the past
four or five months and no doubt the
work that they'll continue doing i it is
appreciated now it's been
a challenge and will continue to be so
so just from the group
it is very much appreciated thank you
thanks councillor evans um cancel the
vote please
[Music]
thank you chair uh it's just a question
for quality on
page 86 5.7 it's regarding the council's
long-term investments uh uh
there was uh taking on 2015 5 million
pound
which was placed in the ccla property
fund for a mini minimum period of five
years
uh obviously for the finishes this would
have finished this year i don't know how
long it's actually
extended for but uh
it's it's obviously it's in a negative
situation
and and so being put on so as a result
of the coronal virus
uh but there seemed to be very positive
comment on 5.8 to say that
there's likely to be a bounce back in
values commencing 2021
uh i'm just wondering whether this uh
whether the the fund was the investment
was for five years and perhaps it would
have been timely to have
taken it out this year or was it a case
of is it extended or
how long it's for and you know the
possibility of losing even more money on
it
i think we're thankful for nikki there
it's one for nikki i mean i'm just
thinking back to about five years ago
when i raised these concerns in the
in the opposition so yes i mean nikki
nick i mean it will
i think the trends in the assessments
are that it's okay but i'll let nikki um
come in and answer it
i i think um i think the thing about
these um
investments in things like the the ccla
property fund is that they are long-term
investments
um we get a very good return um from
this
far far better than we get from um
any anywhere else that that we put our
money really with the
interest rates as they are at the moment
um
the the capital value of it does go up
and down
um for years um after i
arrived the the capital value was below
our
purchase price because she paid stamp
duty
and so so i think last year was the
first time that it managed to sort of
tip over above
above the purchase price it has gone
down
um very slightly but uh at the moment
it's one that we would be intending to
hold on to in with the view of it
um probably re climbing up again but
obviously we review all of our
investments on a regular basis
yeah are there any other questions or
comments on
on this item
no okay so the report is just for noting
can that be noted
please thank you
um item nine is the executive response
to
the children and young people scrutiny
committee task and finish
um on ehcps and the process
in trafford um councillor heinz please
yes many thanks leader um i'd like to
start really with a bit of an apology
actually for
the amount of time that it's taken to
bring this report back
to the executive and members might
recall that the task and finish work
um into ehc plans
for children with special educational
needs and disabilities
came originally to the executive in
september last year and actually the
initial response was ready um
and and was prepared by the first of
february
um and we were just waiting for the
opportunity to kind of bring
this back and present it um
but obviously since then we went into
the altered pandemic
um arrangements um so this has meant
that the
uh the response has been delayed really
as a result of that
um and although we are still obviously
in the pandemic arrangements we did
think that it was really important to
provide a response
um because we do know and appreciate
that the task and finish
um group are rightly quite anxious
um for us to do this um
and although the time frame has been far
from
from ideal and i think it has given us
the opportunity actually to
provide an updated response um
which kind of captures some of the more
recent
activity um and i think this can be
found
in the strategic send ambitions plan
um which is at appendix one of the
report
and this plan outlines the vision and
ambition
for send services and i would like to
sincerely
thank the task and finish group and the
children and young people scrutiny
committee
and everyone really who's been involved
in this incredibly important piece
of work um the executive and officers of
the council have produced a
response um and i would like to thank
the officers
as well for their work in compiling this
and a lot of work has gone into that
um the task and finished report raises
some
areas of concern um which you know we'd
like to
to assure members really that we do take
incredibly seriously
and the response details the steps that
the council is taking to address
these concerns and we've been really
concerned actually about the time
frames of the delivery of ehc plans
um which have been outside of time frame
um in the past um and
but we do very much welcome the
significant improvements in performance
in this area
we know that the team have worked
incredibly hard to clear the backlog
and to reduce the numbers of plans being
issued outside of the time
frame um but you know we also want to
acknowledge that this remains an
important priority
um as it is you know completely
essential
that children are assessed and supported
appropriately
at the earliest opportunity and
and although we are pleased to see these
improvements we also recognize the
concerns that have been raised
and with regards to the quality of plans
and
this is a key area of focus and we're
very keen to see the progression of the
quality assurance framework
um that's currently being developed and
the executive is also very eager to see
the send peer review take place
and this was scheduled for may this year
um but unfortunately this has been
temporarily put on hold
and because of covid and the pandemic
has also impacted the inclusion charter
um for schools which was launched
earlier in the year
um however following the the full
reopening of schools the aim will be to
embed this
within the school community to ensure
every school
in trafford is an inclusive school
understanding the experience of children
young people and families
is critical in ensuring continuous
improvement
and the executive welcomes and
encourages initiatives to support this
including proposals for a parental
walkthrough
of the service and a project to develop
develop
an outcome-based framework for send
and this was recently launched through
training from the council for disabled
children
and the executive believes that clear
and supportive communication is vital
so that families understand what health
is available and the rationale
for any decent decision making and we
champion the strengthening
of relationships with traffic families
traffic parents forums schools providers
and our communities and we very much
welcome the positive work
of the communications and engagement
group that is being undertaken
in order to support parents through this
often very confusing process
and the task and finish group made a
number of recommendations for
consideration
and a response has been provided to each
and it's important to note the positive
work that's been undertaken to date
whilst recognizing there is still more
to do
um again the send ambitions plan
reflects the work
that is planned um and the executive is
committed
to continuous improvements um for send
provision
um and will monitor progress against the
ambitions
plan and the task and finish group have
requested the executive support then to
carry out further work
and we would like to confirm our support
for this
and the report is for noting by the
executive
um and um it's also intended that it
will go
uh back to scrutiny um whether that be
the pandemic uh scrutiny meeting or
um or other arrangements um
but this will give members the
opportunity
um to ask any questions um and discuss
the response and any next steps so
thank you leader thank you
councillor heinz are there any questions
or comments from members of the
executive
no um before i open up to your questions
or comments more widely counselor denise
weston is on the call who is the
chair of the children young people's
scrutiny committee
um and i'd just like to invite her to
make any comments she may have
councillor weston
i'd just like to thank um officers and
also the um
executive member for um producing this
report
i'm happy at this point to take it away
um
to present to the committee um whether
that be
when we next meet as a cyp scrutiny
or indeed in front of the pandemic
scrutiny committee
with your permission counselor acton um
i'd also like to thank
the members of that particular task and
finnish group who worked so hard
to put this together thank you leader
thank you and if you could pass on as
councillor heinz said our thanks to the
committee i know this has been a
significant as well as a very important
piece of work
um are there any other questions or
comments on this
paper
no okay well the response and report is
for noting before i ask exact members to
note i should
also offer a specific word of thanks to
councillor carter who isn't on the call
and but as lead member for education i
know has also been involved with this
along with
councillor heinz and and members of the
children's services team
um okay so can that be um noted in the
recommendation accepted
please
and then i think just let me double
check trying to do an agenda off my
phone
um that brings us to urgent business and
i'm not aware of any items of urgent
business
so i will draw the meeting to a close
thank you very much everyone
for your attendance thanks bye now